[MUSIC PLAYING]
JON MALMAUD: Hello, everyone.
My name's Jon, and
I'll be talking today
about TensorFlow.jl, an
interface between Julia
and TensorFlow.
So what is Julia?
Some of you have probably
never heard of it.
It's a really dynamic yet
performant programming language
developed at MIT since
around 10 years ago.
It's a fresh rethinking of
what a scientific programming
language can be like.
And version 1.0 was
finally realized last year
to this cheering
audience from JuliaCon.
So I'm going to give you
a whirlwind tour of what
Julia is and then talk to
you about TensorFlow.jl.
So here's a very
simple Julia program.
I think anyone with
a Python background
can guess what this is doing,
except this @show business,
but that's actually a macro.
And what is Jon?
I'm finishing my PhD at MIT.
I do machine learning
by day and open source
software by night
and sometimes by day,
too, to the chagrin
of my advisor.
So why consider Julia?
For one thing, it's got
an ultrafast just-in-time
compiler.
So here I'm running an
autoregressive process
using for loops, which I
think is the most natural way
to express them.
And why don't we just run that
for 100 million iterations
in Julia and Python.
And you can see the syntax looks
pretty similar between them.
Well, Python takes
about 13 seconds.
C takes about 0.9 seconds.
Julia takes about 0.95 seconds.
Not bad.
And you have powerful
metaprogramming.
So anyone from a LISP
background will appreciate this.
You can write a macro that
takes in Julius syntax
and outputs Julia syntax.
So here's just a
trivial toy macro
that checks if a number
is less than zero
and prints out a warning.
And note that
since it's a macro,
it can print out the
name of the variable
and change the
variable in place.
You can't really do that with
a normal Python function.
And there's this really nice
multiple dispatch system
where you can define multiple
versions of a function,
and the one that's
called depends
on the types of all the
arguments at runtime.
So here's a really cool
rock-paper-scissor example
that someone from the
community created.
And what's nice is I can
say that for any shape,
if shape A beats shape B,
then shape B loses to shape A.
And I can encode that
information with one line.
And Julia's growing fast.
We've about doubled in GitHub
stars in the last year alone.
We're probably above 20,000 now.
Things have really
started to take off
since 1.0 was finalized.
And now TensorFlow.jl.
So here's a quick
glimpse of its syntax.
It's clearly inspired by Keras
and the whole Tensor 2.0 world.
We're now eager by default,
but graph mode is available.
If you choose to use graph
mode, macros will help you out.
So here a macro is transforming
native Julia, the control flow,
with this while loop into
a graph mode while loop.
And macros can do other
nice things for you.
Here we're visualizing a
program with TensorBoard.
And note that the
labels on the nodes
are automatically inferred
from the variable names, which
is what macros enable.
Macros can do other cool things.
So Francois of Keras fame
posted this really nice example
of implementing
a model in Keras.
But someone replied
to the tweet,
being this is really pretty,
except why are there all these
x's?
I wish we could eliminate those.
And I've highlighted
those in red.
And luckily, there's a Julia
macro that will automatically
thread a variable
through a program,
and so we don't need
those x's in Julia.
I think that's pretty elegant.
And you can benefit from
really fast preprocessing.
So if I want to
tokenize my corpus,
maybe it's got 100
million tokens,
and I have a custom
tokenization scheme,
I can just write
that as a for loop,
and I can trust Julia's
just-in-time compiler
to do the right thing.
You don't want to
write a for loop
in Python that goes over
100 million elements.
You can try.
If you're worried about
leaving Python, don't be.
We have lots of good
scientific computing languages
right in Julia.
If you need to use Python,
we have a very good Python
interface.
So here's an example
of calling into ScyPi.
If I didn't tell you those
last two lines were Julia,
you'd probably think you
were just writing Python.
It's very simple.
And we're compatible with the
whole TensorFlow ecosystem.
TensorBoard works.
Note again that the label
on the TensorBoard graph
is automatically inferred
from the variable.
You can save graphs
in Julia, load them
in Python, and vice versa.
And soon you could do that
for save models as well.
So if some of your
collaborators are using Python,
don't think you have
to switch to Julia.
You can use Julia
yourself and still
work with your Python friends.
And someday they
might use Julia.
If you want to define
a custom operation
and use Julia's just-in-time
compiler to make it fast,
you can do that.
Maybe you want to
write a ray tracer.
You can use Julia's
really easy C form
and function interface,
if that's a part of it,
and define a gradient in that.
And just a little case study.
You can even use Julia's
differential equations package,
and that all just works because
of Julia's multiple dispatch.
So if you wanted to
do a [INAUDIBLE],,
like you might have seen
at [INAUDIBLE],, that's
very simple.
All right, so we still want
to do a lot more Keras.
We need your help.
Come check out our GitHub,
come join our Slack chat,
and download Julia today.
So I just want to thank
all my collaborators,
especially Lyndon,
who's in the audience,
and everyone in the
TensorFlow world.
And I want to thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]